are you on Las Vegas Boulevard
where's the person that stabbed her she
ran I was having my dad can you help me
okay
that is one of the stabbing victims
calling for help the woman pleading that
someone help her co-worker who was also
wounded luckily many bystanders came to
their aid
Casino somebody has been stabbed
we'll come down calm down
somebody's coming you're okay honey
all right you're okay
okay
yes yes she's just scared
so that is a woman Inside the wind who
helped one of the victims that actually
went into the casino uh bystanders also
helping police track and find that
suspect later to be identified as this
man the 32 year old Yanni Barrios
there is a guy that stabs somebody else
somebody else has been stabbed as well
okay he's gonna sell the outfit he's in
a chef outfit a chef hat chef hat okay
I'm sending the paramedics to help you
now she said no it's gonna be uh it's
HMA when white people think that he was
a chef and then he had with the chef hat
with a knife was it a kitchen knife by
any chance
it was a kitchen knife okay
officers caught Barrios just minutes
after that call unfortunately 30 year
old Maurice digiovanni and 47 year old
Brent Hallett lost their lives in this
senseless attack most of the other
victims are out of the hospital Barrios
will be back in court on January 12th